kim kardashian and more stars jump into
sierra's party and the cc train is going
off the tracks with her latest single
jump
the singer recruits some of her famous
friends for a now viral tick-tock
[Music]
yep sierra passes the phone to her
girlfriend's lala anthony lotto kim k
plus vanessa and natalia bryant but the
fellas jumped in too
[Music]
gotta love jay balvin and dwayne the
rock johnson for being up for the
challenge but can we especially give it
up for the rock hitting his signature
eyebrow rays
we've been pretty hyped since last week
when sierra first invited her adorable
family to try the trend at the dolce
gabbana fashion show in italy
who can miss sierra's mini-me sienna
really serving up the sass
sienna is is is the cutest thing in the
world
and she's got so much personality and
the singer kept the a-less cameos coming
we're talking sharon stone lupita
nyong'o drew barrymore ellen pompeo
helen muran and anita
of course these tick tocks are equally
as impressive as sierra's music video
for jump
from the outfit changes to the choreo
cece delivers here's the princess of r b
giving us janet jackson vibes with her
style and dance moves
[Music]
then sierra and her girlfriends get in
formation rocking a sexy swim look
[Music]
and we're getting throwback 90 vibes
with all her oversized and bucket hat
looks
one thing certain sierra always knows
how to keep her fans entertained it's
incredible it's an incredible feeling
[Music]